so I made a quantum computer in my last
video you don't have to watch that video
because I'll try and explain what this
does as I go but when I was making that
video I realized that my quantum
computer seems to be working kind of
well enough that I could actually use it
for a computation that is really
surprising I didn't expect it to be this
good to be honest I thought it would be
so cool to show you a Quantum
computation in action and I hope that by
showing you that you'll get an idea of
what it exactly is that quantum
computers can do well and what they
can't do well because one thing I'm
absolutely sick of as a person who you
know used to research Quantum Computing
is people telling everyone in the media
that Quantum computation is going to
solve all the world's problems quantum
computers are super super computers
they're really not quantum computers are
usually worse than normal computers
worse in the sense that they're about
the same but they're way harder to build
uh but there's some situations where we
have an algorithm for how to use the
quantum computer that lets it do
something that would be basically
Impossible on a regular computer as in
would take a really really long time so
the classic example is factoring prime
numbers on a regular computer that takes
a really long time for even like you
know 30 digigit numbers and that's an
important problem because all of our
encryption currently relies on that
problem being really hard for hackers to
do but on a quantum computer people
discovered an algorithm that would let
you do it quite quickly if you did have
a working quantum computer and I think
that since then there has been this idea
that like we will find um lots of
algorithms to do useful things on
quantum computers
and by and large it hasn't really panned
out it's been almost 30 years since the
factoring algorithm came out but somehow
while I was editing this video a new
polinomial time Quantum algorithm was
discovered finally I'll talk about that
result and how significant or not
significant it is another time but let's
get back to this video I want to explain
why it's so so difficult to make a
Quantum algorithm good so the thing with
my quantum computer is that it is a one
cubic quantum computer literally as
useless as it gets in terms of quantum
Computing so I have to think of an
algorithm that
will be possible on this useless machine
and luckily there kind of is one it's
actually kind of my favorite algorithm
to teach people because it really
demonstrates what quantum computers do
it's called the deuts joer algorithm
Richard joer is actually my PhD
supervisor and he gives a great
explanation of this algorithm and how it
shows what quantum computers can do well
um so I'm going to try and pass on that
same intuition for you I've just got to
try and figure out how using the
equipment that I have so it's an
experiment for both you and me okay let
me explain the problem that the de Jer
algorithm is trying to solve suppose
you're approached by this Shady
character who wants you to solve a
riddle he has a computer in this black
box doing some sort of mysterious
calculation and you can send in a zero
bit or a one bit into the computer as an
input and then it will return one bit as
an output so for example you can send in
a zero and his computer will send out
maybe a one in this riddle he's going to
ask you to find out something about this
secret function his computer is
calculating if that sounds like a
completely ridiculous madeup problem
that's because it is the reason that the
do Jer algorithm was made to solve that
problem is because it's most obvious
problem to solve with a quantum computer
not because it's a problem you would
want to solve so with that in mind let's
try and do it there's four different
functions that this guy might have in
mind he might for example be thinking of
the function that does nothing to your
inputs so if you put in zero you get out
zero if you put in one you get out one
or who might be thinking of the one that
swaps them so if you put in zero you get
one if you put in one you get zero or it
could be one of these two constant
functions where no matter what the input
is you get a zero or no matter what the
input is you get a one so those are the
four different functions the question he
wants you to answer is not which of
these four functions is his secret
function that would actually be too hard
a problem for the quantum computer to
solve instead what he wants you to find
out is whether the function is one of
these balanced functions so like FS1 and
FS2 it's called balance because half of
the outputs are zero and half of the
outputs are one or whether they're
constant functions like F3 and F4
because both those outputs are the same
this seems like a really easy problem if
he lets you use his computer at least
twice you would first send in a zero and
then let's say you got the output one
and then you know that you know it's one
of these two and then you'd send in a
one and if you got the output zero then
you know it's F2 and so you know it's
balanced on the other hand if you got
one you would know that it's F4 and so
it's constant so it seems like a really
easy problem as long as he lets you use
the computer Compu twice but that's the
cat he's not going to he's only going to
let you use it
once can you still solve this problem
the answer for a normal computer is no
way but what about if you have a Quantum
version of this same puzzle can you
solve it with a quantum computer well
first he has to actually make a Quantum
version of this puzzle that's fair
pretend with me for a moment that we are
that guy so we need to come up with a
way of doing our computation that is
going to be kind of fair for the quantum
computer um what I mean by that is that
like the quantum computer isn't going to
be able to act in the exact same way
like its input is going to be a cubit so
you know that's going to be some light
the light is going to shine into the
computer and then the output is also
going to be some light so we need
something that will like do the same
kind of computation but is able to be
encoded in light um so I'm going to show
you one way that we could
make that happen and at first it's going
to seem really strange this strange
computation you're about to see me make
that is actually possible to make
directly from the original classical
computer so if this Challenger wanted to
he could just give the classical
computer to the quantum person and then
the quantum person would have to do the
work to convert it into a Quantum
version and it is totally possible it's
just a bit of a pain and a little bit
mean so instead we're going to like
Pretend We're a nice person and we'll
make something that encodes that
function for
them so that is what we're trying to
make right now Quantum version of f
let's just say for example that the
secret function that we want to encode
is F2 so Z goes to one and one goes to
zero so that is a balanced function so
how are we going to go about making our
secret version of F2 first I'll give you
the sort of theoretical version of it
and then you and I both are going going
to have to figure out how to actually
make it in this experiment remember that
there are two different outputs that
could be coming out of this laser one
type of light that it can output is what
we're going to call horizontally
polarized light or um zero so we'll
write it like that and the way to make
it is to put
a
filter on this light like this and as
long as the filter is aligned this way
then all of the light that come comes
out is going to be horizontal so that
means light that's oscillating in the
horizontal
Direction and there's also light that is
in the one
state which is light that's oscillating
in the vertical Direction so up and
down what we want is both the zero and
the one inputs to get converted in some
way according to what function we have
the most obvious thing to do in this
case is have the zero light become the
one light and the one light become zero
in this case unfortunately though that's
not going to work because if this box is
going to be made of quantum Parts it
actually just can't operate this way the
reason is a bit technical it's because
Quantum processes have to be reversible
and sometimes this scheme won't be
reversible it's not important though
because we can overcome this
inconvenience pretty easily and still
encode the function that we want so this
is the way we're going to do it you see
here we've got zero and it goes to one
whenever anything goes to one what we're
going to do is take the original light
and flip it so this is what I mean so
here's the light coming out in the zero
State and what that means is if you had
an electron in the way that it would
first get bumped upwards and then as the
light moves along it would eventually
get pushed
downwards and then back up so this
electron will be bouncing in this
direction but
crucially originally it gets pushed
upwards now what if I flip this light
upside down then what would happen first
is that the electron would get pushed
downwards so it would still oscillate up
and
down but it would first go downwards so
that is a different type of light very
subtly different but this negative
version of the light is one that pushes
in the opposite direction
first so whenever the output is one we
flip the light on the other hand the one
input goes to zero and the way that
we're going to encode that is nothing
happens so the one just gets to go
through exactly as it was so in other
words if we had this light coming
through it just goes through as if
nothing happened so this action is what
we need our secret quantum computer to
do remember but we're still the guy
right now so that's what we need to
figure out how to do just so you see how
this works if we had another function if
we had F4 it would be
01 and both of those go to one what
would happen is that okay well this bit
is still the same the zero goes to one
so zero gets flipped but now one goes to
one here and so it needs to get flipped
as well so one will go to 1 so if F4 was
our secret function then that is what we
would need our computation to do all
right so that's all good in theory this
is the part that I understand well but
now we're going to have to figure out
how to actually do this I got this stuff
that I I'm really excited about
um uh I don't actually know how to
pronounce this one Lambda I don't know
um you know how you say stuff like oh a
halfwave plate or a quarter wave plate
this is a full wave plate then I guess
um right this is what it does it takes
any light and it flips it upside down so
whether you have a zero coming in or a
one coming in it flips it upside down
which incidentally is exactly what we
need for F4 so that's cool um we figured
out how to do F4 so in the case of f4 if
that was this guy's secret function then
he' just put this
here that would be it I don't think this
is right actually actually I think I'm
getting confused about what these wave
plates do no I was right the first time
that is how you make F4 but then I spend
40 minutes confusing
myself that and that you got vertical I
have no idea what I was talking about
here eventually I decided to just do an
experiment to find out what the wave
plate does easiest way to tell if it is
right is to actually do this this full
experiment so maybe that's kind of good
just putting this um thing here because
uh I want to protect this polymer it's
not really rated for using lasers and I
don't want to burn a hole in it it was
very very painful to watch myself
struggle through this experiment so I'm
going to summarize this bit for your
sake first I tried putting this light
through the quantum computer without the
wave plate in the way and I did a bunch
of measurements of that light using a
filter which I tried orienting in a few
different ways so far so
good
then I put the wave plate up and I tried
the same measurements and you'd expect
some sort of change in the outcomes
right because after all the wave plate
is meant to change the light that's the
point but strangely all of the results
were exactly the same as if the wave
plate wasn't there at
all
what so in other words nothing is
happened here so what I'm going to guess
is that this plate one that I have here
is the one that just takes
anything so whether that's zero or
whether that's one it takes it to the
negative version of itself the thing is
that if um if you have something that
does that it just takes absolutely any
light to the negative version of itself
that's very hard to detect that change
in the light so the difference between
light that's coming in at Zer and
negative 0 is very very difficult for us
to detect it won't work to just use one
of these um because remember like zero
light is horizontal light and negative Z
Light is also horizontal light but it
just starts in the other direction this
this filter just filters any light in
horizontal Direction so whether that's
you know Zer or negative Z doesn't
really make a difference um and so
that's I think why we're getting these
unobservable changes here so yeah that's
kind of good like we figured out what
this plate does
it takes any light and it flips it so if
I had lights traveling in any direction
like let's say this direction um it
would become this light instead which
yes again is very very hard for us to
detect so that means that we were right
earlier this is F4 so F4 is the function
that takes Z to one and one to one the
behavior we want for the machine that
represents a function is that when
whenever the output is one it flips the
light and because the output is always
one for F4 it should flip any light
coming in so okay great this is F4 I'll
label
it and we can stop worrying about
it
okay now let's figure out how to make F2
okay remember that if I wanted to send
in zero light I put this little filter
in in this direction whereas if I want
to send vertical light then I have to
put it in in this direction but as you
can see that opens up the possibility of
putting it in in any direction why don't
we put this in at 45 degrees all right
so this light is originally this 45°
light which by the way I'm going to
start calling PL it's the conventional
notation I don't love it but that's fine
so plus is equal to bit of zero and a
bit of one but remember we can just
think about those two components
separately so we can think about the
zero component and the vertical
component um as kind of like separate
entities and then we can think about
what happens when you add them back
together so both of these are coming out
of the laser in equal amounts and then
um what this polymer is going to do is
it's going to slow down both of them but
it's going to slow down the vertical
component more than the horizontal
component and so they go out of sync
with each other the vertical component
should be up to here
instead now we have light that's
pointing up and to this side so the
combination is as if we had light
pointing this way which I can show you
on a little diagram so originally we had
the um vertical component of Light which
I'll call one and we had the horizontal
component of Light which I'll call zero
and when we added them together we got
plus so the 45°
light but then what happened when the
light went through the polymer is that
this light got slowed down quite a bit
so when it should have been pointing
upwards it was so slowed down that it
was actually pointing downwards instead
the negative version of the same
vertical light all right so that's
what's happened to those two components
but what's the new sum then if you have
some light that is pushing an electron
this direction and downward
the total is as if it's pushing like
this which we call minus um
again I don't really love that but that
is the convention so
0 minus 1 is what we call minus that's
what's coming out so you had this plus
State originally where both the
horizontal and vertical components are
exactly in sync with each other after
the polymer just the vertical component
gets slowed down and so it's as if you
have this minus light instead where
they're a little bit out of sync with
each other and the way that I can tell
that that's what happened is because um
if I had the plus light then what should
happen is when I do the measurement
aligned with the original direction of
the filter then um we should get most of
the light going back through and instead
when I put it at like 90 Dees to that I
should get most of the light get a cut
on the other hand if I had minus it's
the opposite CU minus is pointing this
way and so 90° to plus and so if I have
the filter aligned with the Plus instead
I should see most of that light get cut
out because that's 90° to the
minus and let's see if I put it in like
this you can see that pretty much all
the light gets cut out when it's at the
45 de so that is exactly what you'd
expect and if I put it here you can see
that most of the light light goes
through and so that tells us that this
light that is coming through this
polymer must be in the minus
Direction which is great news so we've
designed F2 we're almost done with our
work but we have two more functions to
go and they're really easy at this point
just write a little label telling me
that when I Orient it this way this is
F2 okay but making fub1 one is going to
be really really similar because um here
this is F2 at least when it's oriented
this way but I'm pretty sure you can
make F2 really really easily now because
if I
just Swap this the direction I
think it's going to do what we want
because um remember originally we said
that this thing was slowing down stuff
in the vertical Direction but not as
much in the horizontal direction right
but if I just flip this over now this is
still the slow Direction but now that's
aligned with the horizontal axis and so
if I put that in here the slow direction
is now the horizontal part and so this
goes slowly whereas the vertical part
goes through Fast And so there's still a
lag between them like they're still out
of sync but it's going to be the
horizontal that lags
the vertical that goes through without
any problems this is basically the same
as what we had before but if we draw
this on a little diagram where we had
one
here zero
here and the zero is going to go to here
instead now so this is negative 0 we
originally had
plus and it's going to become this
thing but if you think about it this
thing is very similar to that
other result we got which was called
minus it's exactly the same as minus but
in the opposite direction flipped and so
it's just minus
minus so this output is basically minus
it's not going to really look different
to us when we try and detect it with
this filter so remember if I put this
filter in here at the 45° angle then it
does nothing whereas if I put it after
the polymer you can see it cuts out
quite a lot of the light on the other
hand if I put it at 90° so
that it lets through most of that light
so like
before this piece of polymer is doing
exactly what we want but we just have to
orient it in a slightly different
direction this is
F3 sorry f 1 this is F1 Okay cool so
this little thing is F2 and fub1 and
this was
F4 all right one last one to do and
thankfully this one is really easy F3 is
the one that takes 0 to Z and one to
zero remember if the output is zero then
you do nothing so in other words for the
zero light coming in in the horizontal
direction do nothing to it for the
vertical light that's coming in like
this is uh do nothing to it so in total
do nothing in other words if our secret
function is F3 then you will put this
box here the super secret box and you
know the person who has the quantum
computer um and needs to solve the
challenge will probably think that
there's something in here but unbeknown
to them there actually
isn't it just hit me that like
I am right now trying to make a real
quantum computer with real Quantum gates
in it
like that's so crazy I I mean how nuts
is it that I study Quantum Computing for
so many
years and I never did anything like this
like I never actually tried to build
anything and so I had like no
appreciation for for this and how much
work it is I had the idea to explain the
doy show their algorithm on my YouTube
channel ages ago um
but
it really didn't occur to me that I
would actually be able to show it to you
this is really
cool okay so now the role of the
stranger is pretty much done they're
just going to come around and put down
their super secret Quantum version of F
and we won't know what's inside you know
it could be this oriented this way or
this way or it could be this one or it
could be nothing at all we don't know
which of those four possibilities it is
and it's going to be inside of here now
you and me have to try and solve this
problem by making a quantum computer
around this Quantum box we pretty much
actually solved this problem when we
were trying to figure out how to make
this thing um but let me explain anyway
there are these four fun functions and
we don't know which one of them is going
to be represented by the Box um but we
just have to be able to use our quantum
computer one time to figure out whether
it's one of these
two so these are the balanced
functions or whether it's one
of these two they're the constant
functions so let's think about how you
might do it one way is just to send in a
zero State and figure out what comes out
on the other end so um it could be a z
or a minus 0 if it was a minus 0 then it
must be that the output is one so zero
goes to one so it's one of these two
it's either F2 or F4 um but that's not
any good to us because then we'd be over
with like we'd only get that one shot
and we sent in something that only
narrows it down to F2 or F4 and that
isn't enough to solve the problem by the
way you might be wondering if I sent in
a zero so horizontal light and I got
negative horizontal light so ne0 would I
even be able to tell that something had
happened to the light the answer is you
wouldn't be able to tell using a filter
like a filter can't tell the difference
between those two but it is actually
possible to tell the difference between
them I used to think it wasn't like in
theory land we kind of treat these two
things as if they're the same we say
that they're off by a global phase and
global phases aren't measurable but
that's not true in theory we always just
pretend that there is no way to tell the
difference between these two but the way
to do it is to use a beam splitter and
then do constructive and destructive
interference experiments on the two
branches afterwards it doesn't really
matter I'm just pointing that out
because it was very interesting to me to
realize that this is true but anyway not
important because this scheme isn't very
helpful just sending in a zero is going
to tell us a little bit of information
and not the information that we need the
same thing if we send in a
one if we get for
example -1 out that's no good to us
either because um well that means that
one goes to one so it's either this one
or this one so F1 or F4 but I mean again
we don't know whether it's balanced or
constant and we've wasted our one turn
of using this secret machine so we need
to do something more clever so like we
were doing a little bit earlier why
don't we put this in at 45° all right
remember that 45 degree light is the
combination of zero and one light let's
pick one of these four functions to be
the secret function in our example maybe
let's make it F1 so F1 takes 0 to zero
so zero just does nothing whereas it
takes one to one which means that the
one component picks up a phase so it
gets
flipped
so instead of having 0 + 1 we have 0
minus one and that is a different state
of light a very special Quantum thing
has happened here if we were just
sending in either zero or one we only
get to find out what it does to one of
the like inputs right either the zero
input or the one input but if we put in
the 0 + one it exactly encapsulates what
the function function does to both zero
and one so in other words this state
does actually contain all of the
information about exactly which one of
these four functions it is F1 does this
to that input and I just quickly write
this out but depending on what this
function is it will send this state to
one of these four and if you can figure
out exactly which one it is then you'd
be done you would know exactly which
function we're dealing with and so you
could tell whether it's balanced or
constant but if you try and figure it
out the naive way which is just by
measuring the state in the zero or one
basis so if you put this filter down
like this what are you going to get in
all of these four cases the light is a
equal combination of horizontal light
and vertical light the difference is
just how in sync or out out of syn they
are but the filter will only tell you
what fraction is horizontal and what
fraction is vertical and so in all of
those cases it's going to say that you
know half of the light is horizontal and
half of it is vertical so no matter what
the secret function is this measurement
is going to cut out 50% of the light and
so seeing that is completely useless to
you and this is a general thing by the
way so with Quantum Computing you might
think it's super powerful because um if
you have some function that you want to
calculate on a whole bunch of inputs you
can put in a superposition of these
inputs so you can do Z plus one and if
there were more inputs you could do a
superposition of all those inputs and
you can send it into your computer and
the quantum computer will genuinely do
that calculation on every single one of
the inputs and your state your final
state will be a super position of um you
know those outputs for all of the
possible inputs but then if you go to
measure it what's going to happen is
that it's just going to collapse to one
of them so instead with a quantum
computer what you have to do do is you
have to take all of those inputs and
find a way of cleverly combining them
such that when you measure now you're
going to just get out the bit of
information that you wanted and this is
super super tricky most of the time and
I mean most of the time it's not
possible or at least maybe it's possible
but we definitely haven't thought of it
and it's very very very likely that it's
not possible but this is an exception in
this case it is all going to work out
for us the way to do it is exactly what
we saw earlier where say this is my
secret function this is
F1 arient it like this what this does is
if the light is from fub1 or F2 then the
light is going to have gone from being
oriented in this 45° angle to being
oriented like this or the negative
version of that and so that means that
if I put the filter
in in this direction Direction it should
all just go right through whereas if I
put it in at 45° it should get cut out
so let's just do the measurement in that
direction so I'm going to put this in at
45° and you can see that indeed it cuts
out most the
light so we can be pretty sure that the
light is coming in at this direction on
the other hand let's say the function
had been F3 well then the light was
coming in at 45° originally and nothing
happens to it and so if I put the filter
on like this in the same same
measurement it should do pretty much
nothing to the light and that is what we
see if we put it in at the opposite it
should pretty much cut it out which it
does so that is what will happen to F3
if we have
F4 what it does is it turns light that
was 45° into light that is the opposite
which is pretty much the same it's going
to go right through this filter
regardless and you can see that that is
what happens when I put it in at 45°
whereas when I put it in at 90° to that
it cuts out almost all the light the
upshot is the only measurement you'll
need to do is to turn this filter at
45° and that's how you solve this
Quantum riddle using the doy joser
algorithm first you send in plus light
and then you measure the output at
45° to prove to you that you know how to
do quantum comput now I'm going to be
that guy and I'm going to challenge you
to a game so I'm going to put down a
secret function in here and I'm going to
let you see what happens when I put this
filter in at 45° and from that you're
going to have to guess whether my secret
function was a balanced or constant
function so my secret function is ready
now I'm going to put this filter in at
45° and that cuts out most of the light
whereas if I put it
in here essentially no
change so is my function balanced or
constant